مرحبًا رافي، كيف قمت بتحويل الشرير
إلى شخص بداخلك ولكنه أيضًا
مألوف جدًا للجماهير، كما تعلمون، لقد أضفت
ما فعلته في غرفة المعيشة عندما كنت
طفلاً، إنه دائمًا لطيف ما نحبه حقًا
هو مجرد صناعة الأفلام، فهو دائمًا ما يراه
الجانب الجيد من الناس، نعم هذا
صحيح تمامًا، فهو شخص نقي القلوب للغاية،
لا ما رأيك في هوليوود اليوم
كبيرة وأكثر تنوعًا، أعتقد أننا وصلنا
إلى النقطة التي أصبح فيها هذا الأمر
أكثر طبيعية، كيف تشعر بكونك
جزءًا  من هذا الفيلم، لا من فضلكم فقط
ماذا عنكم يا رفاق من فضلكم، استمتعوا بالرقص لقد
كنت مرعوبًا للغاية عند مشاهدة
هذا الفيلم، لقد قمتم بعمل رائع، شكرًا لكم،
كانت هذه وظيفتي لإخافتكم،
كيف كان الأمر عندما كنت متحدًا مع
طاقم التمثيل القديم لهذا الامتياز  أعني بصراحة
أنه كان حلمًا تحقق في الشرق
الأوسط، فنحن نحب أفلام هوليود ولكن عندما
يتعلق الأمر ببوليوود، فإننا نحبها أكثر، أعتقد
أنه ربما من الناحية العاطفية
نحن على مفتاح أكثر تشابهًا في
رأيي، فهو أحد  أفضل الحركات التي
رأيتها منذ وقت طويل جدًا، خاصة
مشهد دراجتك النارية، أوه نعم، هذا
التسلسل بأكمله مذهل جدًا،
لم يكن علي القيام بأي من التدريب
الذي كان على كل هؤلاء الطيارين القيام به، لقد
بقيت شخصيتي على القارب، واو، هذا
نوع من الدور البطولي ساندرا،
سأبدأ معك أولاً، كيف
ارتديت بذلة الرجل لأنني لا
أعرف ثلاثة أربعة أشهر، وهو أمر
غير مريح للغاية،
لكنني أعتقد أن ذلك كان جزءًا من
سحرها كدولة شرق أوسطية  نحن
سعداء جدًا برؤية الممثل التونسي كجزء من
هذه السلسلة المذهلة والمبدعة،
حيث تقول إن
المكسيكيين الفخورين في الشرق الأوسط
يحبونك وهم متحمسون للغاية
لمشاهدة هذا الفيلم، هل يمكنك التأكد من أنهم
يعرفون أنني أحبك؟  لهم كثيرًا
ذكرى سنوية سعيدة، شكرًا لك
الذكرى العشرين السعيدة قناة العربية الإخبارية، شكرًا
لك صبا العربية لمتابعة
أخباري دائمًا، أنا بول فورمان، شكرًا لك، الذكرى
العشرين السعيدة، قناة الأخبار الإخبارية، شكرًا لك
على متابعة أخباري دائمًا، أنا
كارولين من باريس من سوبر  الكثير من
الحب الذكرى السنوية السعيدة